his work is all reading has a must-see
material for a good reason do the right
things school days mo better blues usual
suspects playing Jorge in the Maze
Runner film series and of course in
Breaking Bad better call Saul as Gustavo
Gus fring welcome back to the show from
better call Saul that you can catch
Monday nights right now on AMC in season
four Giancarlo Esposito good to see you
sir great to be here it is for us
Breaking Bad fans and I will speak on
behalf of the millions I don't care I'll
do it
am I allowed to a mile of you're allowed
okay it is a blessing it is like eating
cotton candy watching you back again as
a real sob nasty nasty individual what
is it like for you to have this
opportunity you know it's a blessing
it's a it's a blessing to be able to not
only be excited about a show but then to
look at it in a different way as Gustavo
Fring and Breaking Bad I had one mindset
of a guy who really takes control but
who's affable and lovely and nice you
see him in many different incarnations
and those players hermanos also you see
him behind the scenes cultivating his
network in better call Saul you see a
younger version of him someone less
careful a little more edgy someone who
is bound to possibly make a mistake but
someone who's building up their empire
and so I love being able to find the
nuance in this new version of Gustavo
Fring and I think the audience will be
excited to see it as well well I mean we
just showed a scene radio audience from
season four just a couple of weeks ago
where you tell a character nacho who
thinks that he's about to maybe finally
get out of this life of crime and get
through it that you watched him try that
an attempt that I don't want to tell too
much but you now own him and you deliver
the line of you are mine when you see
that on the page what do you think I
think I have to go to a very calm and
dark place to tell another human being
that I owned them it's it is a little
bit frightening to read on the page but
as I
divorce myself from my emotional
feelings and fall into that very cool
and cold place to be able to deliver
that message I feel powerful how many
takes did it take you to do this one get
out on that night
there was some undue tension on the set
I'll leave it right there so I decided
to get even a little more brutal and a
little more ruthless by divorcing myself
taking myself away distracting my energy
from the other actors for a reason
because I wanted to be able to give it
all when the camera rolled
so folks got a little bit frightened and
asked me what was wrong what was wrong
what was wrong and I said we're not
gonna talk about it now I'll show it all
when the camera rolls we have a really
wonderful group of actors on this show
everyone works in a very different way
and they have different expectations
about how they do was seen and sometimes
we agree and sometimes we don't and it's
when we don't agree and we agree not to
agree that sometimes the magic happens
so that's what happened on the set that
night that's what happened on the set
that night there we was late it was cold
wind was blowing through this very the
tin corrugated garage there was a little
irritation um it was just a little bit
off and I decided to use that energy and
projected onto my scene partner in a
very different way than he had ever
experienced we both came to find out in
those moments that we got one of the
best scenes ever which was really
wonderful I agree with you man I mean
and now you you could see from the
Breaking Bad community and the better
call Saul community that they that they
felt the same way about that scene and
so when you nail the line and you stick
the landing they use the sports phrase
yeah stick the landing always take the
homerun I know they'd out of the park so
when did did nobody dare say let's try
that one more time well we had a
director who was an interesting guy but
I think he was a little bit frightened
of our or cowed by this particular cast
so he was he was very kind and very nice
and actors like to be sometimes dealt
with in a different way so I think he
just looked at my face and knew that was
it taken you you know that's it you know
we don't need to do any more that's the
answer so after it was over did any of
your cast members come up to you and say
are we good now or they are s you're
okay that they did you know I think
there were hugs all around because they
realized and for me you know I play my
roles very much like a method actor in
television because there's no time
there's no time and for me to be
chitchat and corner and then come and do
a scene I don't feel like I really have
the omething that and that don't bring
the past history of what's happening it
through my being and through my eyes and
through my voice so I stay quiet so I
can nail it you can nail it Giancarlo
Esposito here in the Rich Eisen show is
there anyone that you've worked with
previously or it may be early on in your
career who had this similar style of
acting that was tough for you dang get
used to on the set where you were the
one asking is everything okay well no
one really comes to mind okay to be
honest with you I I did do a play with
Delroy Lindo and I noticed he had the
same rhythm that I did okay he got
through the theater at four o'clock in
the afternoon and we don't even go on
till 8:00 so a lot of preparation went
into his mindset of what he was about to
do James Earl Jones is another actor who
I found could zip in and out of being
jolly but on certain nights he would
come in and speak to no one and and just
have his intention in the forefront of
his brain and Boyd was he absolutely
marvelous sure and then the voice comes
out as Darth Vader and then you're
really scared it's interesting so it's
like you know we talk all the time in
sports about quarterbacks weren't you
and needed to be the first in last one
out is that the same thing in actors
that you would that's how I feel
you know I linked up acting with sports
through spike spike is the ultimate
coach and I started to think about that
you know how do you feel when you're
getting me I was a baseball player
myself when I was young Little League
you know I always had a certain real
gusto gusto for the game because it is
like being a gladiator going into that
forum that Coliseum
so for me it's it's what you think is
the projection of what will become and
it's it's almost coordinating that I
hand coordination that you have to have
when you're swinging the bat it's that
that it's a music it's a rhythm and that
for me acting is that way it's
interesting that you say that in terms
of also Spike Lee also because when you
hear the phrase also in sports speak it
into existence when when there are
players athletes he or she says
something out loud and you feel it's
brash maybe but they have to believe it
before they actually accomplish it
absolutely you have to really feel like
inside that it's gonna happen and think
when you're at the plate and you're you
know you're two strikes down you know
it's hard not to feel defeated but much
better a vision to see that ball going
out of the park
who was your who's your guy growing up
or gal growing up at you Sidney Poitier
what a wonderful actor he is I got a
chance to meet him a few years ago he
was someone that really affected my
whole life and my whole consciousness in
regard to who I was as a man as a human
being
forget race or color because he
transcended all of that he became you
know a human being and for me one of my
one of my greatest idols hmm what about
athlete my athletes man well you know I
think we're gonna get to baseball so I
hate to sort of give it away okay now
let's take a 60-second break come back
do that when we come back and we've got
some great facts from your career that
we were gonna play celebrity true or
false we always have fun doing that with
our guest Giancarlo Esposito here on the
Rich Eisen show at quiet hand films on
Twitter to follow him a better call Saul
can be seen every Monday night on AMC at
9:00 Eastern Time back with Giancarlo
Esposito in 60 seconds
[Music]
all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show another segment here with Giancarlo
Esposito of better call Saul and
Breaking Bad all right now who are your
you're from your you were born in Europe
correct toured in Europe Poland Kaufman
Copenhagen Denmark raised in Rome Italy
came to New York and became a huge
Yankee fan in my day hmm and during
those formative years for the Yankees
they seem like they've always been on
top and okay have such a great record
but yeah I live in New York for a long
time so are you fluent in Italian yeah I
wish because you know it's funny because
John sterling the longtime voice of the
Yankees is using a an Italian phrase for
a home run call every time Giancarlo
Stanton hits a home run even though his
real first name is John and he's from
the valley here in Los Angeles at mic
stands like Mike's ten Mike's Mike's the
extent and he was going what did he
change his name a few years ago I'm not
sure come on that was his choice yeah
yeah Wow I love it no wonder he never
answered me when the guys caught me
outside of LA and they asked me who's
the other great John Caudill or who I
said I want to go and be the game with
him you know so I'm still gonna shout it
out John Cottle oh I gotta get there you
got we got to get together I know
and it's amazing Yankees have the second
best record in baseball and they're so I
wouldn't say panic mode but when you're
looking up the Red Sox are 50 above 500
Yankees are 9 games out just like it's
kind of just like because we were
talking off off off camera 240 years ago
was the Bucky Dent home run when the
Yankees came from almost as far back you
know that's right what a terrific time
that was 1978 I think they're the only
team that won in a tiebreaker to this
day right but you had I guess we had
Bucky Dent with that home run which was
a three-run homer pretty incredible but
Ron Guidry on the mound Wow that's right
you know Ron Guidry the ball looked like
it was coming out of his glove and
slow-mo you know that and all of a
sudden would catch up and he didn't
pitch as hard as other pitchers but he
had the control and then of course he
gives it up to goose Gossage
just it was one of my favorite closers
ever that's right this famed phrase cuz
Sparky Lyle the year before was saw
young and then when goose Gossage came
the famous line was that Lyle went from
siyoung to sayonara aside it's one of
the all-time great lines horizontal team
as well
Torrez was on the Yankee team in 78 yep
when and then the he was on the Red Sox
before that Wow it is truly remarkable
I know you don't want to talk about you
want to talk about 5000 that's right yes
yeah last time yeah well you know we
love you you be happy right now right
now but John coddle is your is your
given name correct Giancarlo is my given
name yes it is and then is it true your
middle name is Mike I'll say it all for
you what is Giancarlo Giuseppe
Alessandro Esposito piacere oh I get a
little head yes it did fantastic so who
was your player growing up then who was
your player growing you know I loved
runners you know I love this guy Dave
Waddell you know what that was it just
I'm a real running enthusiast and had
been for a long time but you know Dave
Winfield was one of my favorite Yankees
sure he always came through you know
these are the we got youth they could be
back now they're Reggie Reggie was
pretty fantastic as well as straw that
stirs the drink yeah Wow
I know that's what hit that was that was
crazy times back in the 70s so is it
true that there are pop-up polos
hermanos stores in Los Angeles in New
York this week are you aware of that
oh yes I am aware of that we did one
down in Austin okay they bring in the
trucks with the you know the four walls
and the roof and they're serving my
curly fries so you have to get there and
do you show up in the in the gear I have
showed up well I show up in this gear
you know no you're dressed in the and
then oh I didn't dress in the polos
yellow because I wanted to be more
Gustavo as opposed to the manager of the
restaurant or the owner of the
restaurant
but we have a great time doing these
around the country started with South by
Southwest last year and I was really
amazed I mean like you could live and
eat off the floor in my restaurant but
that's the way it should only know one
speed as they say oh no what speed so
lean do you do people like see you and
think that you are in fact Gustavo
we're got a doubt this happens so much
of the time people you know many don't
know my name and it's just and Gus is
easier than Giancarlo so it's very
interesting I when they see me break a
smile or become a little bit animated
than they were they're disarmed to a
certain extent but otherwise people give
give space and I like that when they
give me a little room all right well I
want to play celebrity true or false
with you if you don't mind compelling me
here okay Giancarlo I wish I could say
you're a whole full minute ball cito
here on the Rich Eisen show go for it
first up celebrity true or false you
Giancarlo Esposito where one of the
chorus of children who sang the theme
song of The Electric Company true we're
gonna turn it on we're gonna bring it up
our what yes you know I got a chance to
to go for an audition for that and I was
also auditioning for Sesame Street at
the same time they said you're not gonna
get this but we're doing a spin-off on
The Electric Company we want you to sing
the song in the studio and make some
guest appearances so they said to you
how old are you oh my goodness I was
like nine years old so they said to you
nine years old hey look we can't put you
on the street but we got the company for
you that's right we're gonna can you
let's you got The Electric Company but
we couldn't we can't fit you on Sesame
Street had done that sure early on and
he was easy reader he was easy reader
wow where we come from oh yeah oh yeah
I'm is easy reader yeah I could do that
song off the top of my head - so that's
Wow unbelievable next one originally
hector salamanca of Breaking Bad and
better call Saul was supposed to be the
main antagonist but Vince Gilligan
expanded your role as Gus fring and made
you the bad guy instead is that true
false
boss from what I understand unless
there's something I don't know I do love
um Hector Salamanca well I hate him I
love marshmallows who plays him mm-hm we
did a play thirty years ago called bomb
and Gilly out in New York John Malkovich
and Gary Sinise plethora of other really
wonderful actors but one of my favorites
to work with on this particular show and
returning again here in better call Saul
is mark Margolis just a seasoned
wonderful amazing interesting so did you
know when you first took the role of
Gustavo Fring then it would be as long
as the arc would last as long as it did
you kidding me man I was in and out
guest spot I was just so tired of guest
spots I had done so many of them wanted
to have the opportunity to do an
extended role and so I did it because I
was I looked at it I said send it to me
I turned him down a few times they sent
it to me I loved it was happening so I
expected to go into it a guest episode
and be out got off the plane from that
first episode and my phone was ringing
they want you back right away
and for the last episode of season 2 and
I I said okay I'll do it
and that just kept going like that and
now here we are and here we are yeah and
you were and you were first nominated
for your role in it in 2012 here we go
in 2018 oh it's amazing that Breaking
Bad it's been such a time has passed
since I was there as Who stubborn
Breaking Bad never thought I returned to
Saul
really loving that I have very different
show very slow burn very it's a smaller
playing field
which allows the opportunity for such
great writing that Frank you Lynette
Gilligan has provided and also Bob
Odenkirk yes is just a powerful force in
this dramatic show and also funny as
well yeah he is no doubt about it
another one your first screen credit is
clay Tainan in guiding light
is that true was that your first true
Wow you do your homework well really was
excited to do that show because I was
doing plays at that time soap operas
like a play I was a bad guy then as clay
fine now yeah burnt down the gym play
further down the gym another boy stray
come on come let's rob a convenience
store when he wouldn't do it I said only
burn the gym instead so is it your your
skills so Pok opera skills that got you
on trading places as well I think you
think it's very very power
you know at that point in time you know
things were I was a little larger than
life so I had to learn how to tone it
and bring it back of course with Gustavo
you see that I probably succeeded in
that effort but then people need energy
people want to be around good energy
which is why by those what I keep coming
back here because you have such a great
energy thank you yeah appreciate it
yeah no it's the truth so when I did a
film night on earth and I was sitting
with Paul Auster wonderful author and
Wayne Wang wonderful director we want
your energy to start off this film so
very similar in trading places you know
to be a background player but then to
have enough energetic energy level to
play behind a guy like Eddie Murphy
pretty much of an honor yeah what is was
it like on the set is that was that a
fun set or was that set
could you get with medians and they're
loose man they're not like they're
actors like we I'm like thinking oh I
get nervous just coming here man like I
can sit and talk about myself oh my gosh
what am I gonna say right right but
actors on set are always in their lines
or they're trying to think and comedians
are loose they're talking like you know
sports yeah they're talking what's going
on in the world so it allows them a
different entry point and Eddie was just
at that point in time the funny is going
over one of me this is red hot red hot
note so nobody walked up to Aykroyd that
dance is everything all right you're the
wind throw my gosh thanks for coming
back please keep coming back oh it's
such a pleasure
you got a great audience we love your
audience we love your radio audience
thank you know we love you thank you
right back at you Giancarlo Esposito
check him out and better call Saul it is
as brilliant as ever the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience